El área superficial de un cubo es igual a
la suma de las áreas de sus 6 caras.
Veamos esto, siempre es bueno visualizar las cosas.
Si este es el cubo, si este es el cubo,
podemos ver 3 caras...
3 caras son las que estamos viendo de frente,
pero si fuera transparente podríamos ver
que de hecho son 6 caras las del cubo.
1, 2, 3 caras al frente,
ésta en la parte de abajo, ésta en la parte de atrás
y ésta también en la parte de atrás.
En efecto el cubo tiene 6 caras.
El área superficial de un cubo cuya arista mide "x"...
ésta de aquí es "x", ésta de aquí es "x"
y ésta de aquí es "x"...
está dada por la expresión "6x" cuadrada.
Sí, se verifica, cada cara tiene un área
de "x" por "x", "x" cuadrada y si son 6 caras,
el área superficial es "6x" cuadrada.
Julia tiene dos recipientes de forma cúbica
que quiere pintar.
Un cubo tiene aristas de longitud 2, uno de
los cubos tiene aristas que miden 2,
vamos a dibujarlo aquí, este es un cubo cuyas aristas
miden 2, 2 y 2 y el otro cubo tiene aristas
que miden 1.5, vamos a hacerlo por acá,
un poco más pequeño, este es el otro cubo,
cuyas aristas miden 1.5, 1.5 y 1.5 aquí.
¿Cuál es el área superficial total que
ella tiene que pintar?
Bueno, sabemos que el área superficial de
cada cubo va a ser 6 por "x" cuadrada,
donde "x" es la longitud de la arista del cubo.
Entonces, para este cubo, el área superficial
va a ser igual a 6 que multiplica a...
déjame escribirlo con el mismo color del cubo...
6 que multiplica a la longitud de la arista
del cubo, las dimensiones del cubo,
ancho, largo y alto son las mismas, la longitud
de la arista, así que sería 6 por la longitud
de la arista que es "x" elevado al cuadrado,
6 por 2 al cuadrado
y para el cubo más chico el área superficial va a ser 6 por la longitud de la arista que en este caso es 1.5,
elevado al cuadrado.
Y si queremos el área superficial que ella
va a pintar, va a ser la suma de estas dos áreas,
así es que tenemos que sumar estos dos términos.
Calculemos esto entonces, esto es 6 por 2 al cuadrado, 6 por 4 = 24, más 6 por 1.5 al cuadrado,
veamos 15 al cuadrado es 225,
así es que 1.5 al cuadrado es 2.25,
así es que 1.15 al cuadrado es 2.25 y 6 por 2.25...
no... no es tan fácil directamente,
hagámoslo por acá...
sería 2.25 que multiplica a 6.
Tenemos entonces, 6 por 5 = 30, llevamos 3,
6 por 2 = 12 y 3 = 15 y llevamos 1,
6 por 2 = 12 y 1 = 13 y el punto decimal que lo
corremos dos lugares, es 13.5,
así es que esto es más 13.5.
Hacemos la suma de estas
dos cantidades, 24 más 13.5,
esto es igual al área superficial total
que tiene que pintar que es 37.5.
Y esta área estaría en las unidades...
no, no nos dan unidades,
así que sería simplemente 37.5 unidades cuadradas.